ah
mirar al sur ese fue el nombre que
recibió la gira del presidente mexicano
andrés manuel lópez obrador por cinco
países de centroamérica y el caribe
guatemala el salvador honduras belice y
cuba fueron las naciones que hicieron
parte de este tour que tuvo como foco
fortalecer los lazos de amistad entre
estos países y méxico pero sin duda
alguna el tema migratorio y también la
puesta en marcha de planes sociales en
centroamérica fueron los puntos fuertes
de esta visita amplio fue muy enfático
en decir que la migración es parte de la
condición humana lo que sí es
reprochable son las causas que la
provoca al menos así fue lo que dio a
entender durante su paso por tegucigalpa
la capital de honduras el ejercicio de
la libertad de tránsito
les agradó
pero es
intolerable
el que muchos se vean forzados a
abandonar su lugar de origen por hambre
por inseguridad
o por total carencia de horizontes de
vida
el mandatario de los mexicanos también
hizo referencia a la necesidad de
mayores compromisos a nivel económico
por parte de eeuu país al que le
solicitó más recursos para tratar la
crisis migratoria mientras que
washington está cada vez más concentrado
en el conflicto en ucrania
cosas distintas
no se debe comparar la tabla raza pero
ya se aprobaron más de 30 mil millones
de dólares
a apoyar
en la guerra a ucrania
y llevamos
cuatro años
desde que estaba el presidente donald
trump
planteando
que se apoye con 4000 millones de
dólares
y hasta el día de hoy
no hay nada
méxico y cuba han mantenido muy buenas
relaciones a lo largo de los años con
sus altos y sus bajos pero méxico ha
conseguido mantenerse cercano y sin
complicaciones tanto a washington como a
la habana esta multipolaridad digamos ha
sido una característica de la política
exterior mexicana y también es una de
las apuestas de amlo en su materia de
política exterior desde la capital
cubana lópez obrador rechazó que algunos
países como cuba por ejemplo hayan sido
excluidos de la cumbre de las américas 1
un evento que está organizando eeuu en
la ciudad de los ángeles para el próximo
mes de junio
insistiré
con el presidente baile
en que no se excluye a ningún país de
américa
en la cumbre
del mes próximo a celebrarse en los
ángeles california
y que las autoridades de cada país
decidan libremente
si asisten o no a dicho encuentro pero
que nadie excluya a nadie
preguntas que dejó sobre la mesa para el
debate que dejó esta gira del presidente
mexicano por centroamérica que busca
exactamente el presidente mexicano
posicionarse como un gran hermano para
los países centroamericanos busca
congraciarse aún más con eeuu en cuanto
a sus labores contra la migración y hay
un dato que llama mucho la atención esa
búsqueda para estrechar lazos con belice
que es un país centroamericano
angloparlante pero que con el que tiene
innumerables posibilidades de negocio
pero es un país que no está muy
integrado con el resto del continente y
mucho menos con américa latina' entonces
pues llama la atención esa visita que
hizo a la ciudad de belice en donde se
encontró con el primer ministro de este
país hoy en el debate de france 24
hacemos balance de la gira de amlo por
centroamérica y el caribe y para
analizar este tema saludamos aprenda
stefan él ya es analista internacional
ella se encuentra en ciudad de méxico
también allí en la capital mexicana se
encuentra álvaro ramírez él es
politólogo especialista en opinión y
ustedes nuestros televidentes también
pueden participar en el debate con sus
comentarios y sus preguntas lo pueden
hacer a través de las redes sociales de
france 24 no se encuentran en facebook
en instagram y en twitter estamos como
france24
bajo ese y santi logo mi cuenta personal
les recuerdo que nuestra etiqueta es
numeral el debate efe 24 esperamos todos
sus comentarios y sus preguntas
relacionadas con este tema comienzo
entonces dándole la bienvenida a brenda
stefan ella se encuentra en la ciudad de
mexico brenda gracias por acompañarnos
hoy en el programa y comienzo como punto
de partida para el debate su balance de
esta gira los puntos positivos los
puntos que faltaron lo que se puede
destacar de esta gira del presidente
mexicano por centroamérica y el caribe
santiago muy buenas tardes gracias por
la invitación al programa pues yo creo
que para méxico el tema de centroamérica
es una tarea pendiente desde hace muchos
años si bien estados unidos y méjico
hablaban de voltear a centroamérica e
integrarlo en una estrategia regional
esto se consideró durante años como algo
importante pero no urgente y se fue
dejando del lado yo creo que en ese
sentido es una buena noticia que haya
una visita del mandatario mexicano a
centroamérica y una mirada hacia el sur
porque independientemente de cualquier
cosa para méxico estos países son su
frontera sur y representan un tema
estratégico en diversas materias social
seguridad económico etcétera el tema
quizás no tan bueno es esta intención de
exportar programas que no han sido
probados como eficaces es decir
normalmente cuando se busca llevar a
otras latitudes una política pública es
porque ésta ha sido evaluada como muy
exitosa en el caso de los programas
natalio mexicano busca exportar los
resultados pues son magros en algunos
casos no hay información sustantiva para
hacer una evaluación
en los efectos de estas y creo que en
ese sentido pues la visión de de atacar
las causas de raíz es buena pero no
necesariamente esta es la forma de
hacerlo por último decir que la visita
cuba tiene una lógica muy particular
todos los presidentes de méxico desde el
triunfo de la revolución cubana han
visitado la isla no es algo nuevo no es
algo que sorprenda pero sí el tipo de
mensaje es muy de apoyo al régimen
cubano y de crítica al embargo es algo
más particular digamos de lópez obrador
yo soy
partidaria de que las sanciones de eeuu
han fortalecido al régimen y que es y
que más que ayudar a debilitar lo han
fortalecido en ese sentido creo que hay
algo de verdad pero no así la defensa de
las violaciones a los derechos humanos
la opinión de prenda este fin en ciudad
de mexico y allí también en la capital
de la república mexicana está álvaro
ramírez con nosotros también le doy la
bienvenida al programa álvaro su balance
de la gira lo positivo y lo negativo lo
que podemos destacar de este encuentro
con los diferentes mandatarios
centroamericanos y con el presidente de
cuba
hola santiago la prenda buena buena
tarde bueno a mí me parece muy peculiar
estas visitas porque no hay que olvidar
que tan solo
no sé dos años solo mucho ha habido
cerca de 26.000 personas migrantes que
han sido deportadas tan sólo 11.000 a
guatemala 11 mil al salvador entonces
estamos viendo que evidentemente esta
exportación de programas sociales sobre
textos del programa social ya sea
sembrando vida ya sea de jóvenes
construyendo el futuro bueno no puede
dejarse de lado que la agenda
prioritaria puntos son los programas
sociales nos es seguir fortaleciendo
este tema de la migración
el presidente de andrés manuel lópez
obrador en el salvador mencionaba que
que gracias a estos programas bueno se
ha reducido drásticamente la migración
no obstante pues los datos dicen otro
otra cosa
está la presencia de estos ciudadanos
guatemaltecos salvadoreños hondureños
a lo largo y ancho de todo el país es ya
significativa y lo podemos ver en otro
ángulo que no sea no hay grandes datos
pero podemos empezar a observar a través
de western junior que el flujo de
remesas de méxico hacia esos países ha
ido incrementándose en méxico ya no sólo
está recibiendo
y las remesas de mexicanos en estados
unidos o en europa ahora méxico desde
mexico están saliendo remesas para
centroamérica y eso es un punto muy
interesante porque por más que sigamos
viendo a centroamérica como un país
desde el que están saliendo los
migrantes bueno también está ocurriendo
lo mismo que hacen los mexicanos en eeuu
bueno ahora lo vemos con estos
centroamericanos en méxico que están
enviando sus remesas hacia sus países de
origen
está cuestión de los programas sociales
pues también va a ser interesante ver
qué tanta vida puedan decir más allá del
sexenio de andrés manuel porque por
ejemplo el presidente bucl tu mandato si
no logra una reelección concluyen del 24
al igual que el presidente alejandro
giammattei concluyen en el 24 entonces
ahí es a donde habrá que ver yo estoy
totalmente de acuerdo en que en méxico
son programas que el objetivo principal
es sacar a las personas de la edad que
sean de las garras del narcotráfico y
bueno pues el narcotráfico sigue
tejiendo filas y filas de gente
participando en ellos bueno te vamos a
analizar un poco más en detalle tipo de
programas quiero abordar otros temas
antes de llegar a ellos comienzo con
álvaro para hacer la ronda a la inversa
aprenda ya le doy la palabra más
adelante y quiero entender cuál es el
papel que el presidente mexicano quiere
que asuma méxico en esta crisis
migratoria y en la región de
centroamérica pero enfoquémonos en el
tema migratorio cuál es el papel que
tiene que asumir este país o por lo
menos lo que el presidente tiene la
intención que méxico asuma
bueno cuando inició el seccional andrés
manuel lópez obrador él hizo una
declaración un tanto contundente ya que
él decía que méxico era un país de libre
paso como lo mencionó antes en su
discurso en guatemala y eso nos trajo
una fuerte llamada de atención porque
bueno hubo reformas y el propio
presidente de la mesa directiva de la
cámara de diputados del momento señaló
que se estaba utilizando a la guardia
nacional como muro de contención y
desafortunadamente apenas trump pues lo
vuelvo lo volvió a señalar y dijo bueno
nosotros no tuvimos que poner un muro en
la frontera sur de méxico porque ellos
pusieron al ejército entonces creo que
es un tema que sigue siendo delicado en
la agenda del presidente andrés manuel
lópez obrador por su concepción
ideológica principalmente él es una
persona que bien lo mencionaba de
santiago viene del sur viene de estas
entidades donde hay una gran presencia
de ciudadanos guatemaltecos porque es
una cuestión histórica es una cuestión
cultural entonces el perseguirlos y no
dejarlos llegar hasta la frontera
pues no somos un país que esté
acostumbrado a estar haciendo esto no
tenemos esta visión de verlos como
criminales como si nos criminaliza por
ejemplo los eeuu entonces creo que si
sigue sigue siendo y seguirá siendo la
piedra en el zapato de este gobierno
ideológicamente identificado como la
izquierda el tener que perseguir
deportar y reprimir a los inmigrantes
como lo hacen como lo solicitan los eeuu
como lo piden washington y le piden
cierta forma a mexico brenda su opinión
sobre este tema sobre el papel que
quiere hablo que asuma méxico en esta
crisis migratoria con centroamérica y
bueno y también los migrantes que llegan
desde otras partes del mundo a través de
centroamérica a méxico para poder llegar
a eeuu
yo creo que uno es el papel que quiere
anv lo que méxico asume hay otro es el
papel que eeuu quiere que méxico asuma y
creo que ese es el que ha sido el que ha
regido el actuar del instituto nacional
de migración y de los controles por
parte de la guardia nacional desde
aquella amenaza del trump en mayo de
2019 de aumentar los aranceles a los
productos que vinieran si méxico no
contenía los flujos migratorios pues
desde ahí méxico ha aceptado de alguna
manera convertirse en una primera excusa
para los flujos migratorios en un primer
control
continuamente mes por mes el instituto
nacional de inmigración sigue enviando
a migrantes a sus países de origen y
esto obedece sí
claro al
y cierta visión de este gobierno pero
sobre todo pensaría yo a una visión de
washington en donde ellos tienen un
sistema migratorio completamente roto
santiago la legislación estadounidense
no les permite gestionar de una manera
integral el fenómeno migratorio y
realmente tienen muchos vacíos en la ley
que no logran cerrar o no logran llegar
a un acuerdo bipartidista para atender
este tema y entonces lo que se ha hecho
es exportar este problema hacia méxico
de ahí el establecimiento de programas
como los mal llamados protocolos de
protección migratoria que no es otra
cosa que el quédate en mexico donde
méxico por primera vez acepta recibir
nacionales de terceros países que están
esperando la resolución de sus casos de
asilo o refugio en estados unidos y que
son trasladados a territorio mexicano se
quedan en la frontera norte en nuestro
país y pues también en condiciones de
vulnerabilidad ante la delincuencia y la
inseguridad de esta región entonces qué
de alguna manera esta gira también se
inscribe en esta idea el viernes de la
semana anterior había lópez obrador
tenía una llamada con vaivén había
también viajado el canciller mexicano a
washington y después vienen todos estos
mensajes a centroamérica sobre el tema
migratorio un tema muy álgido
políticamente para washington y sabemos
que de cara a las elecciones de medio
término en la administración baiden le
confiere una importancia mayor
brenda entonces desde el punto de vista
de washington esta gira puede ser vista
como positiva
en washington y méxico han jugado con
esta lógica en la que en tanto méxico
con pere en temas que son vitales para
eeuu y particularmente para este
gobierno demócrata se le permite hacer
otro tipo de comentarios al mandatario
mexicano sin generar presión como si
hubiera pensado hay quien dice cómo es
posible que méxico haya invitado a él mi
gente hubo a un cubano a una celebración
nacional en nuestro país y que eeuu no
haya dicho nada me parece que la
explicación está justamente en los
controles migratorios que está haciendo
méxico a nombre de eeuu de alguna manera
símbolo problema interés de cooperar en
el control de tráfico de estupefacientes
para ti particularmente el tema el
fentanilo
sabemos de la crisis por sobredosis de
fentanilo en eeuu y éste llega a méxico
desde china por barco a los puertos y va
hacia el territorio estadounidense me
parece que la casa blanca está dispuesta
a hacer oídos sordos siempre cuando haya
cooperación de este gobierno en estas
materias álvaro dejando un poco de lado
el tema migratorio
brenda decía al inicio de su
intervención que centroamérica era una
tarea pendiente para los gobiernos
mexicanos para para gméxico en sí porque
ahora si miran a méxico centroamérica
independiente de esta crisis migratoria
que hay del problema que hay en el
triángulo del norte pero siempre se le
ha criticado a méxico por no querer ver
a sus vecinos del sur que cambio ahora
bueno ahí un poco lo que había estado
ocurriendo tenemos que venimos
tres gobiernos que nos habían querido
fijar o atender esta problemática que
había estado en aumento a los gobiernos
anteriores sin decir que este está
haciendo un mejor papel por supuesto en
el caso específico
al menos están empezando a tratar de
atender recomponer un poco la relación
sin embargo insisto en este punto de
vamos a tener que esperar a ver qué
tanta continuidad pueda haber no sabemos
quién sea o de qué partido provenga el
siguiente gobernante en méxico y cuál va
a ser el vaya a ser el tratamiento que
le vaya a dar a las relaciones con
centroamérica igual y entramos en nuevo
en una etapa
de distanciamiento o no porque pues si
los eeuu comprenden o que ya no son los
mexicanos los que estamos pulsando una
frontera ahora son los centroamericanos
que están viniendo desde partes de
centroamérica cruzando todo méxico no
sin importar el riesgo que representa
cruzar méxico actualmente pero que está
ocurriendo otro punto también muy
interesante y es que por ejemplo lo
sabemos en el salvador hay un toque de
queda ya por más de un mes donde están
tratando de reducir la violencia que
está imperando en el salvador y bueno lo
que se ha estado observando es que no
hay un control migratorio en el sur de
méxico que te permita tener precisamente
este filtro no decir bueno sí o sea no
sólo son ciudadanos que están buscando
llegar a los eeuu ahora no sé si lo
tienen el dato pero hace poco tendrá que
confirmarse la información fue detenido
un ex militar colombiano que estaba
cumpliendo un cartel mexicano entonces
hay una preocupación evidentemente
porque ya estamos exportando también
mercenarios entonces bueno no estamos
trayendo ex militares pandilleros
entonces ese yo creo que sigue siendo el
gran ojo que está poniendo los eeuu de
decir bueno piensa no hay problema que
quieran intenten llegar bien temen te
los vas a frenar el problema es que se
queden en méxico y que empiecen a hacer
esas actividades en el crimen organizado
y que en mexico evidentemente no vaya a
poder tener la capacidad y que más allá
de que hagan ahora nos hagan aquí en
méxico pues puedan llegar precisamente a
los 2000 que creo que es ese su
verdadero temor el riesgo en seguridad
para importante en esta gira del
presidente mexicano fue cuba lo
mencionábamos al inicio del programa
varias declaraciones importantes dio
desde la ciudad de la habana de la
habana importante y tal vez llama mucho
la atención desde otros países de
latinoamérica ese manejo que méxico le
ha dado a la relación méxico la habana
méxico washington siempre históricamente
sobre todo con los partidos como el pri
durante los gobiernos del pri méxico fue
un país que siempre estuvo muy abierto a
las relaciones con la habana y con el
régimen castrista ahora vemos un
discurso renovado vemos un discurso que
cambia con este mandatario como se puede
entender esa relación de méxico y cuba
que se puede ver hacia el futuro sobre
lo que pueda pasar entre los dos países
en términos de cooperación y sobre todo
en apoyo político como lo ve de prenda
en efecto yo creo que desde el triunfo
en la revolución cubana los diferentes
gobiernos de mexico han mantenido una
buena relación con la isla
independientemente de las diferencias
ideológicas quizás en esta ocasión esto
se exacerba porque coincide no solamente
la visión del estado mexicano sino más
bien también un tema de ideología de
izquierda es la relación de cuba con la
izquierda mexicana que representa a
andrés manuel lópez obrador más allá de
que a nivel de su gobierno podríamos
cuestionar largamente si éste es o no un
gobierno de izquierda pero digamos en
términos de la geografía política
mexicana está dentro el expect especto
en la izquierda y esto fortalece de
manera particular esta relación que
parece incluso ya en términos personales
muy buena al escuchar las referencias
que hacen uno respecto al otro en
términos personales pero bueno si
pensamos que peña nieto en su momento a
la muerte de casas pero fue a la habana
y pronunció un discurso que vale la pena
por ahí recuperar pero en donde hace
también digamos una
pues una apología de lo que es la
revolución cubana pues no es algo tan
nuevo en ese sentido para méxico lo que
yo sí creo nuevamente es que el tema
migratorio saldrá en todos los casos es
decir en cada pregunta que nos haga
santiago porque en los últimos cinco
meses ha habido 46 mil cubanos que han
llegado a territorio estadounidense hay
que recordar que los cubanos tienen unas
condiciones de mayor aceptación como
como migrantes que llegan al suelo
estadounidense
pero al mismo tiempo parece que
washington no está tan contento con que
lleguen en estas cantidades
particularmente porque nicaragua a
finales del año pasado levantó el
requisito de visas que tenía para los
cubanos y estos han llegado por esta vía
ya nicaragua después por tierra cruzando
por nuestro país hacia el territorio
estadounidense y parece que ahí pues hay
una visión también de buscar frenar
estos flujos que tanto preocupan a la
casa blanca
y cuál es la opinión de álvaro así en
ciudad de méxico sobre este tema la
relación con con la habana es el llamado
que hizo el presidente mexicano una
revolución dentro de la revolución que
fue una de sus palabras como más
llamativas a lo largo de su visita a la
isla
y santiago históricamente está esta
relación bien lo dice brenda es una
relación que nuestros países han
mantenido bajo diversas circunstancias
los propios pronunciamientos visual
presidente andrés manuel fueron
muchísimo más históricos de cómo han
venido a estas relaciones
patronales que no hay que olvidar que
hace menos de un mes se dio la
interparlamentaria méxico-cuba donde el
grupo de legisladores senadores
diputados que estuvieron en la habana
se llevaron lograron construir este
acuerdo seguir viendo las legislaciones
que se tengan que estar modificando en
ambos países para seguir fortaleciendo
las relaciones culturales
deportivas
comerciales entonces creo que además
méxico sigue siendo este respaldo por
así decirlo político respaldo ideológico
cultural y que además no hay que olvidar
que cuba acaba de estrenar una una
constitución política no entonces no
estamos hablando de la cuba de fidel
castro no estamos hablando de esta nueva
etapa constitucional también que a pesar
de que miguel díaz canel provenga de lo
más adentro del régimen no viene del
régimen militar de un régimen por así
decirlo sin eso no despectivamente un
régimen burocrático
entonces es esta nueva visión que
evidentemente andrés manuel tiene sus
simpatías hacia la isla planes de
gobierno muchos integrantes de este
gobierno tienen las empatías hacia la
isla y que hablar de esta revolución
dentro de la propia revolución pero yo
me quisiera imaginar que está hablando
de no perdamos la esencia no no no
pierdan su esencia a reducción arias de
los cubanos y no se dejen seducir
precisamente por los eeuu hay algo que
me llama la atención
brenda de
esta forma actual del presidente
mexicano a lo largo de estos días
durante la gira lo vimos mostrándose
como una especie de líder regional como
una especie de presidente que puede
hablar tanto con ese gobierno izquierda
que representa cuba como con el gobierno
de eeuu que representa supuestamente las
libertades y la democracia en el
continente se ofreció a mediar por cuba
para que eeuu contemple la posibilidad
de levantar el embargo precisamente por
esa buena relación que hay por lo menos
cordial entre méxico y eeuu y también
habló de renovar algunas organizaciones
como por ejemplo la oea crear una
organización supranacional tipo la unión
europea para que américa latina puede
hacer frente
y actores internacionales como por
ejemplo china aquí vemos a un presidente
tomando un cierto liderazgo regional
tomando esa batuta para liderar américa
latina' en cierta forma como lo
entienden ustedes
yo lo leo de la siguiente manera por un
lado en la izquierda mexicana la
relación con américa latina es
importante históricamente y entonces
creo que también es un mensaje a sus
bases políticas y también en momentos en
los que ya empieza a barajarse una
sucesión presidencial entonces creo que
hay un mensaje interno que se da desde
fuera también creo que lópez obrador no
se siente muy cómodo en el espacio
internacional no es su hábitat no es en
donde él se desenvuelve bien y desde
luego que quizás américa latina es el
único espacio en donde él tenga un
poquito más de confianza para para
presentarse con otros mandatarios a
hablar etcétera entonces creo que eso
también explica
porque va a la región y desde luego sin
duda la crisis que se vive y las
condiciones ya eran complicadas en
centroamérica pero a partir de la
pandemia y de los huracanes que muchas
veces son efectos de este cambio
climático pues las condiciones de los
centroamericanos se llaman de manera
importante en los últimos en los últimos
años y me parece que en ese sentido
méxico que históricamente ha sido un
país de transmigración inmigración e
inmigración
sabe que estos números en los tres
rubros han aumentado particularmente
aquellos que llegan para quedarse en
nuestro país y de ahí la mirada de tal
acción nacional mexicano hacia
centroamérica
quiero pasar un poco más a la agenda
local meternos un poco dentro de las
fronteras de méxico para entender varios
aspectos que fuera de mexico muchos no
no estamos habituados y no y no estamos
muy
unidas muy profundas sobre por ejemplo
estos proyectos sociales de sembrando
vida y jóvenes construyendo el futuro en
méxico reciben críticas estos proyectos
dicen que no ha dado los resultados
esperados el gobierno dice que son
resultados a mediano y largo plazo su
opinión sobre estos proyectos ya ustedes
nos daban algunas luces álvaro comienzo
por usted
si mira el programa de jóvenes
construyendo el futuro de sembrando vida
han sido jóvenes construyendo el futuro
nace de esta idea de andrés manuel lópez
obrador
de decir que los jóvenes que no tenían
un trabajo y no estaban estudiando
despectivamente se les llamaba ninis
entonces la solución el presidente ante
el manuel lópez obrador diseña desde su
momento de ser el candidato en liza
vamos a darles una beca para que sean
contratados y no importa que la empresa
no los pague yo les pago entonces es una
oportunidad interesante sin duda es una
oportunidad que ésta puede tener sus
resultados positivos pero también es una
estrategia que se pensaba para
precisarlo empezar para los jóvenes de
las manos del narcotráfico de que
pudieran caer en actividades ilícitas
sabemos todos que evidentemente lo que
pueda representar la beca de jóvenes que
construyendo el futuro no sea
próximamente podrían ser unos 300
dólares por 150 dólares más o menos pues
no representan un atractivo para un
joven que pueda estar ganando 12 mil
dólares al mes o un poco más entonces en
términos económicos porque si la
quisieran tener un futuro asegurado
estarían trabajando y no serán metidos
en el crimen organizado y el programa de
sembrando vida es un programa que va más
enfocada a estar en el campo estar
sembrando ciertos tipos de árboles para
la producción de alimentos de maderas y
todo esto donde se ha enfocado
principalmente más hacia el sur hacia el
sur del país no pero esta parte que
ahora decías también no por ahí en las
visitas centroamérica se hablaba de este
interés que tienen los países de la
región centroamericana en poder
conectarse obtener alguna manera de
entrar al tema del tren del tren maya no
que evidentemente en caso de tener éxito
pues también les traerá un beneficio de
ellos si dicen qué bien decía no ven de
belice de guatemala son son ciudadanos
que se vienen de fin de semana al sur de
nuestro país y que evidentemente poder
tomar un tren
a facilitar muchos a esta cuestión de
fortalecer el turismo en el sur del país
y brenda su opinión ya voy llegando al
final del programa su opinión sobre
estos programas le pido que sea breve
porque tengo dos temas más para tocar
bueno brevemente nada más decir que como
habíamos mencionado en la evaluación de
estos programas en méxico aún es muy
joven no hay elementos que puedan
indicar que estas políticas sean
realmente eficientes creo que por el
contrario parecen resultados magros y
por otro lado esta idea de exportar
políticas públicas de un país a otro
siempre a pesar de las similitudes que
pueda haber en la región es un poco
complicada cada país en centroamérica
tiene su propia problemática hay que
entenderla como tal ese es el principio
de cualquier política de desarrollo
entender la situación local y después a
partir de ello construir la respuesta y
creo que en ese sentido pues sería
cuestionable tratar de explotar estos
programas álvaro muy puntual por favor
usted que es especialista en opinión
pública cómo queda el presidente andrés
manuel lópez obrador después de esta
gira su imagen a nivel internacional a
nivel local entre los mexicanos después
de lo que las críticas que le llovieron
por él de la crisis de la pandemia y los
reveses que ha tenido por ejemplo con la
reforma energética pero luego la
nacionalización del litio todos estos
movimientos que le han causado pues
críticas y también opiniones a favor
digámoslo así y yo creo que es sin duda
un fortalece su imagen de liderazgo
evidentemente hacia asia las bases del
partido yo estoy seguro que hacia ahora
así que de colombia hasta argentina
la sola presencia de andrés manuel lópez
obrador no representa por ejemplo lo que
podría representar un lula da silva ya
que efectivamente a andrés manuel no es
una persona que esté concentrada en en
conquistar está no sé estar en la
opinión pública latinoamericana de verse
como ese líder latinoamericano yo estoy
seguro que esa no es su intención su
intención es seguirse mostrando hacia
asia méxico como una persona que es
capaz de salir a hablar con otros
líderes mundiales de poder exportar su
ideología hacia otros países bueno no sé
si por ejemplo colombia pudiera aceptar
un sembrando vida argentino disposición
del futuro no o sea tiene que ver donde
lo está haciendo
brenda álvaro dice que no es la
intención tal vez la del presidente
mexicano mostrarse como un líder a nivel
regional o mostrarse en los diferentes
países y usted dice que que no se
desenvuelve muy bien en la escena
internacional pero sin duda alguna tiene
que tener una agenda en su política
exterior cuál puede ser esos siguientes
pasos en la política exterior mexicana
donde pueden ser esos siguientes
destinos que lleven al presidente para
seguir conectando el país
a un presidente que vaya a continuar
viajando digamos este es apenas su
cuarto viaje a lo largo de su gobierno
los primeros tres fueron estados unidos
en naciones unidas y los otros dos a
washington a reunirse con los
mandatarios estadounidenses esto es muy
fácil de entender el 80 por ciento en
las exportaciones de méxico van hacia
eeuu tenemos una frontera de más de
3.000 kilómetros nuestra economía
depende en buena medida de más del
comercio con ellos del turismo
estadounidense y de las remesas que
vienen de eeuu en fin en un tema de
intereses está claro que más allá de que
se ha hablado durante años de
diversificar los intereses de méxico al
día de hoy digamos tenemos una buena
parte de nuestra apuesta en la relación
con eeuu entonces creo que eso podría
continuar la relación con eeuu y con
américa latina' y no veo a un lópez
obrador activo en la escena
internacional de ninguna manera y no le
interesan y creo que lo poco que hace lo
hace como bien señalaba a álvaro para
irse a sus bases políticas partidistas
ideológicas y no tanto para construir un
liderazgo regional y mucho menos global
que no es ni su área y sus capacidades
ni su expertise entonces creo que más
bien tiene que ver con construir su
proyecto hacia adentro de mí
construir un proyecto al interior de
méxico me quedan ya un par de minutos
para finalizar el programa quiero que
hagamos las conclusiones del cierre de
esta gira de lo que representa para
méxico para el presidente para las
relaciones de este país con sus vecinos
más cercanos que son los países
centroamericanos comienzo entonces por
álvaro
si el poder hacer me gustaría decirte
por ejemplo sin duda alguna esta parte
de levantar aranceles alimentos que
provengan de belice es muy importante
tal vez no son las grandes es el gran
comercio que tenemos con belice sin
embargo creo que son resultados
positivos también tenemos que empezar a
fomentar esta cuestión de beltrán el
libre tránsito bueno a sin aranceles
hace de la región centroamericana hacia
méxico
se pueden dar buenos acuerdos no
obstante necesitamos también bien de se
ablanda también esta capacidad de
nuestro presidente porque al final del
día él es el que lo encabeza no digo
andrés manuel de los subsecuentes de
detener esta independencia no también
hacia los eeuu porque hoy en día si eeuu
está muy fuerte en méxico pero no
podemos dejar de ver a china que está
muy fuerte no sólo en méxico que está en
centroamérica que están todos
el continente sur entonces creo que si
tú pudiéramos tener una mayor
independencia sin duda alguna en este
tipo de fortalecimiento de relaciones
con los países centroamericanos a
nosotros como en méxico nos hacía el
valiente y brenda su conclusión para el
cierre del programa
pues de reiterar que es bueno que el
presidente salga del país eso en sí es
una buena noticia es bueno que voltea
hacia el sur hacia centroamérica creo
que es un área desatendida que merece
todo el interés de nuestro país por
diversos motivos
pues como decía álvaro el tema del
liderazgo de méxico no será quizás el
tema central pero smith que méxico no
está aislado no vivimos ajenos a lo que
sucede más allá de nuestras fronteras y
voltear a ver como en esencia más allá
de eeuu no solamente desde el gobierno
sino también desde el análisis los
analistas internacionales en méxico con
frecuencia solamente vuelven a ver lo
que sucede en nuestra región creo que
hace falta una mirada global a prenda ya
álvaro les agradezco por este análisis
de esta gira del presidente mexicano por
los países del norte de centroamérica y
por el caribe ustedes pueden seguir
dejando sus comentarios a través de las
redes sociales sigan con nosotros además
para ver en france 24
[Música]